hey everybody and welcome to a very
sweet wild ride with stevo not only do
we have jody sweden from full house with
all kinds of crazy insights into the
scandalous trials and tribulations of
child actors as well as all this juicy
stuff about addiction and recovery but
this episode is brought to you by the
sweetest brand of cereal out there it's
called magic spoon and it really is
magic because each serving has zero
grams of sugar
four grams net carbs and 13 grams of
protein that's absolutely crazy because
this stuff is every bit as delicious as
all of your favorite cereals from when
you were a kid i don't mind saying that
this fruity flavor
it's every bit as delicious as fruity
pebbles the frosted flavor dude reminds
me so much of cap and crunch and here
this stuff's actually good for you i
mean dude it's a performance enhancing
meal
dude i also don't mind admitting that
totally by myself i went to
magicspoon.com
stevo and i ordered 26 boxes because i
love it so much
yeah i'm running low on cinnamon and i'm
telling you it tastes just like cinnamon
toast crunch i'm gonna eat some right
now dude you guys have to try this man
it is so killer you go to magicspoon.com
stevo
and use the promo code stevo to get you
five bucks off your order and
it's like being back in the game man
eating like you're a little kid except
not feeling bad about it
go over there grab yourself a variety
pack just enjoy man
and they have a happiness guarantee so
if you don't like it for any reason get
your money back no questions asked
tastiest cereal ever
zero grams of sugar per serving
now let's get into it
ladies and gentlemen jody sweden yeah
all right what's up you've met my
co-host scott randolph i have scott how
are you good how are you and uh it's hot
as balls outside but we're gonna run
this air conditioner for as long as we
can yeah we'll we'll run it and then
turn it off eventually and i i speak
loud anyway so i'll just do my best to
project it will
turn off i predict in about
45 to 50 minutes right and if by that
point you've had enough then fair enough
all right now all right
so yeah where to begin i mean
my first thing i'm curious about were
you a child star
before
the original full house
uh i did a lot of commercials and stuff
when i was young before full house i
really full house was one of my first
big television gigs i did uh
i don't know if you remember the show
the hogan family yeah
uh i actually did a guest appearance on
the hogan family as
pamela poole who was mrs poole the next
door neighbor's niece
and it was an episode where she was
watching me and then she like throws her
back out or something and then jason
bateman and
um
the other two jeremy licked and uh danny
i can't remember his last name anyway
they take over wind up babysitting me
but that was my very first tv role i was
four and a half and it was the same
producers uh that were doing full house
the same executive producers miller
boyet
and they loved what i did and they cast
me on full house from that i never
actually auditioned for the show i
basically did a guest appearance on
valerie and they were like this is who
we want for
i was stephanie
lucky and before that i got to do i did
a
sizzler commercial that was really
successful like the ad company wound up
giving me a dog when i was like four
because the the commercial was so
successful and it was like i kind of got
i gave you a dog they gave me because
like it was you know they gave me a dog
because the it did so well and because
originally
they had a boy cast for the part and
they brought me in as a backup and i did
it and they and this poor little boy had
to just stand to the side all day
while they completely changed the entire
commercial to be a daughter they didn't
even have a name for me so they just
used jody like i mean it was
yeah and and it was a sizzler
all-you-can-eat shrimp commercial and it
was a really hugely popular
thing so television commercials have
always been like a really like
good paying thing right a good national
commercial is awesome like you know
people that when you see like those
people in commercials that are doing
that you know the the
whatever the insurance one progressive
all that [ __ ] right they i mean
they're they're doing great off of
somebody
i had a buddy that did a zima commercial
and he got picked up and he made like 90
grand off of it yeah you make a ton off
of
national commercials i don't know how it
is now i mean the business is so
different now from when i started like
it's just vastly different but if it's
based on impressions i would imagine
that it's still very lucrative yes well
i mean now you know if the instagram fee
all that [ __ ] is just basically i say
that yeah okay you can save
it's a wild ride yeah i was like if i
can't say the word [ __ ] on stevo's
podcast i don't know what kind of planet
i'm putting on
um but yeah it's you know it that was my
introduction into it and i was four
years old and then by five i was working
on full house and then that was oh [ __ ]
you were five when full house started
yeah
i was four and a half when i did valerie
and i got cast i was five years old i
pictured you as like the older sister no
candace was ten
i was five and then ashley mary kate
were nine months old
damn
yeah it shows how much i know
[ __ ] what's that like walking onto a set
at five like i mean at that point do you
even know
what's going on oh yeah i was it was
funny i actually just today i ran into
um joel zwick who directed
tons of episodes of full house the
original i met him when i was four and a
half years old
uh he directed our pilot i've known him
forever ran into him randomly today but
he still talks about he's like at five
years old like you
sat at the table reading table you read
that script with everybody else like you
were on it you had everybody laughing at
five i could read the little before my
third birthday
unbelievable yeah did you like that
attention i'm kind of i'm a little bit
of a nerd and and so yeah i've loved
reading my whole life dude i was on an
airplane recently and i watched an hbo
documentary about child stars
and it was like
kind of pretty dark like the whole there
was an indictment of like you know
pushing kids into show business right
which i you know it's unfortunate well
it's not
you know what's absolutely unfortunate
yesterday i had to delete something from
instagram because the hair coming out of
my nose was just disgusting and
humiliating
but you know what's not unfortunate at
all is that all i had to do is grab my
manscaped weed whacker and just stick it
in there and boom nose hair gone problem
solved that's what manscaped does is
solves grooming problems man they got
the new lawnmower 4.0 this is the best
shaving tool out there man it even shows
you what you're doing with the light
boom no nicks no cuts just fresh
shaved balls and body courtesy of the
best
men's grooming device out there
manscaped now if you go to manscape.com
stevo what are you going to get 20 off
your order plus free shipping plus man
it's summertime dude it's time to have
the clothes off it's time to look good
so dude are you gonna be a slob with
hair all over you like scott randolph
or are you gonna get your manscaped
grooming devices and clean yourself up
take off your shirt with pride yeah go
to manscaped.com
stevo and get yourself taken care of by
using that slash stevo 20 off your order
and free shipping and hey you heard it
from me now
let's talk about child stars
it is it isn't i guess my experience was
so vastly different growing up in this
business
like
yes there are some things that come
along with
being famous at a young age yeah but my
overall experience was so wonderful and
positive and like i have this family of
people 35 years later
that i'm still friends with and like
still
are my family
i never experienced any abuse my parents
always were like if this isn't what you
love
we're not gonna make you do it it was
never my parents idea like i wanted to
before
does a four-year-old say i want to go on
an audition yeah really wow i was bet
when i was three years old i told my mom
i would watch tv and i'd say mommy i
want to be a modeler which was the
people that i saw on tv and she was like
i don't i mean i don't know like my
parents were very hesitant i mean my dad
had you know he was a superintendent of
a gypsum plant in long beach harbor my
mom was a stay-at-home mom of a wet
plant a gypsum plant drywall oh wow i've
never heard i don't think i've ever
heard the word gypsum yeah it's like a
drywall union
uh it's like electrician plumber
i'm i don't know i mean
maybe
i think it falls under like dock workers
or something i don't know but my dad you
know had a very blue collar job he was a
handyman all my life
um my mom was a stay homeless huh and
you were in los angeles we were in uh
like lakewood was where we first lived
which is technically l.a county but
pretty far south kind of next to long
beach
and uh so my mom put me in dance classes
and like you know at
my first recital i was in the second row
and apparently i thought the girl in
front of me was just [ __ ] it all up
so i like kind of pushed her out and i
was like i got this and like what you
know my mom was like
i mean maybe she should perform she
really loves it right and i did i i came
alive and still to this day i don't
think i ever feel more
at home
than when i'm on set working like having
all of that going on it just feels like
totally comfortable to me and i never
stopped you know what
in high school i stopped wanting to
audition as much and my mom was like all
right cool
like this isn't what you want to do i'm
not going to drive you around everywhere
and
want it for you
and i took some time off i went to
performing arts high school and that was
it so
it was always my idea though and i
didn't have a terrible experience but i
know
so many people have because and i've
seen it i've seen parents that want it
more than their kids right
that's interesting to say
in high school i didn't want to audition
anymore
where
you think of child stars and and the
dynamic that's sort of like kind of dark
and said like maybe when they grow up a
little bit people don't find them cute
anymore and then they're sort of like
maybe like 12 years old and feeling all
washed up kind of a thing i mean it was
definitely an adjustment at you know at
13 years old i was finishing middle
school which is just [ __ ] for anyone you
know i mean middle school just kind of
sucks right yeah i have two kids that
are going my one is in eighth grade and
one is going into sixth grade and it's
just the most awkward time of your life
right yeah so i finished the show and
i'm starting high school
so it was just i mean
that time of your life when you're like
who the [ __ ] am i you know like
what what do what do i want what am i
doing and i went to a the orange county
high school for the arts i was in
musical theater okay so i still had that
performing outlet
and i did party of five i did a few i
did like a a six episode guest starring
thing on party five when i was a little
bit older and i thought you're gonna say
i did party my ass off
i mean i did but that was like later in
my you know right like high school and
20s when i really
acted like an [ __ ] were you still
going to grade school while you were
filming
they didn't like by law you didn't have
like a teacher on set i had both our
producers again really wanted were
really
involved and engaged in how the kids on
the show were doing
so i really wanted to go to regular
school in the morning and because we
lived in orange county and like traffic
sucked getting up there at eight
we worked it out to where
i think my first season i did
my school on set just because we were
kind of getting into the groove of it
but after that like i went to school in
the morning we worked 40 weeks so monday
i was at school all day tuesday
wednesday i went to school until lunch
and then got picked up and thursday and
friday i did my work on set so i had
like
a foot in normal life and i just went to
a public school in orange county
normal life like i didn't live some
crazy you know yes i got to do really
cool [ __ ] growing up you know but i also
lived a very
normal grounded life and i think that
that
really helped me
be a halfway normal [ __ ] person you
know what i mean like
so if my math is right you were 13 when
you stopped doing full house you were
five when it started so it ran for eight
years eight years we did eight seasons
of that show yeah and five seasons of
fuller house for netflix and so that
means it's super syndicated like did you
get to renegotiate your contract after
like so many years and get like back-end
and stuff
you don't get back-end stuff but you
still get you know some residuals but
residuals people think they're you know
you're making like hundreds of thousands
of dollars you're like it's look it's a
nice little bonus of like i can put a
little bit of money aside maybe or pay
my bills with it but it's not
not everything that everyone thinks it
is you know and now with
netflix and streaming like again like i
said the business is so different like
residuals aren't a thing anymore right
you get paid out up front they pay you
far less than you know they used to on
network shows
and you get paid out and that's it like
you'll get maybe dvd sales and stuff
like that but it's it's a very different
business than it used to be but yeah i
mean look full house has been on the air
ever since it started in 1986 it's never
been not on the air somewhere in the
world
so that's crazy i'll sound like a creep
for asking this but dude do people
always tell you you look like scarlett
johansson
you know what that is that's actually
something that i've gotten several times
and it's a huge compliment because i'm
like if anyone thinks i look remotely
like her i'll [ __ ] take it she's
gorgeous
we saw the black widow or the movie
billboard after i'm like that looks like
the jody that we're gonna on our way to
right now i have actually heard that
before and it's funny because people
come up to me like
can i tell do you know who you look like
and i'm always like expecting you know
the girl from full house and they'll be
like
screw just listen i'm like
thank you
or the girl from vikings i've gotten
that too yeah my girl my girl
loves the show vikings but i never got
into i haven't watched it but i actually
had somebody think i was her on a plane
and was like i know who you are and i
was like okay so we went along this
whole thing i thought one thing and
right this person thought another and
then finally he was like i just love
vikings i have to and i was like
oh that's actually not me we're having
two very different conversations are you
familiar you see you've watched vikings
you're into it i've seen i haven't
watched it i've watched like half of one
episode not because i didn't like it i
just was god only knows what other nine
million shows i was trying to finish at
the time right
right okay
but thank you i'll take the compliment
yeah
i mean
it struck me i was like man there's a
real resemblance there i will play her
sister any day in any movie i'm just
throwing that out there right now
sorry oh go ahead when uh you said you
went to an art school
so like what i was
curious about
years of like child stars
getting like bullied in school oh yeah i
did for sure oh you got bullying school
because you were successful with the
show yeah middle school was really i
mean
elementary school people were rough but
it was like
stupid [ __ ] you know what i mean like
whatever making fun of your name or make
it but but that was like across the
board everyone just you know made fun of
each other but i was with those kids for
a while
then you go to middle school and it's
like now you're dealing with kids from
you know five or six different
elementary schools that you haven't met
before and they're like
you know i would show up to school and
it was like i knew people either wanted
to be my friend because they were
impressed by me
or because
or just wanted to be around me to [ __ ]
with me
and you know i i remember walking
through the quad in like seventh grade
like the first week of school and
somebody just chucked an apple right to
the side of my head from across the bank
you know they'd write [ __ ] on my locker
or like intentionally try and trip me or
like you know as you walk by talk [ __ ]
and i just learned to be like
[ __ ] you you know it gave me a real
thick skin so it prepared me well for
the internet that's for sure do you ever
get any fights
um are you a brawler or no not till not
till later not till later but yeah
yeah i've had a few i mean that was
definitely more when i was just like in
my
addiction and drinking and being an
[ __ ] yeah you know i'm great for like
the first three hours and then after
that i'm like i will fight anyone for
sure
did i did you make it through all the
eight years of full house
without getting loaded or did that start
no that was i was still a kid yeah and
like it really wasn't until high school
which is kind of when everybody starts
you know that's the time 13 14 15 like
you start doing dumb [ __ ] because
everyone's doing dumb [ __ ] at that age
um
but you know i
my
i always say i would have had issues
with addiction regardless of growing up
on tv
i understand addiction in a very
different way now but i also you know i
was adopted at a very early age
my parents both had addiction issues my
biological parents
i was raised by two totally normal
people and i
that was what i found you know i started
partying in high school and i was the
one that it was like i started and i
couldn't stop and i went too far and
people were like
yeah what is wrong with you i was like
i come from a long line like on my mom's
side of the family every single person
like without without exception yeah but
on my biological side it's uh uh you
know there was a lot of addiction there
was a lot of
mental illness but you know coming
actually finding out now as an adult
there was also a lot more
success in some of my biological family
than i than i knew about but you know it
was
i definitely was born with
you know
a predilection to that and then at 13 14
you start going like who am i where am i
from who are my people who i know these
are my my parents but i'm not from them
so like how do i connect with that and
when the only thing you know is like
your parents were addicts and had issues
in and out of jail and
my dad was killed in a prison riot like
you know
when that's what you know
suddenly you feel like oh is that
all that i am is that who i am and i it
took me a long time to get over
that resentment and that hurt and that
all of that that really led to a lot of
my
how old were you when you found out you
were adopted
when you were adopted uh i was
officially 14 months old but it was
right around like my
first birthday a little bit before so it
was about a year
was there a period in between getting
adopted and not being with your
biological parents where you were like
shuffling through the system uh i didn't
get put in the system thankfully but uh
my mom was in jail when i was born
i talk about it we were born in jail i
was born in jail i was born one legend
dude technically uh at the usc county uh
sure on the you know the inmate floor
but yeah floor yep 13th floor
and uh
you know there's like the kick and then
there's
right
yeah
so you know it
luckily my mom had um
and and my biological dad had friends
who
and cousins and family who actually are
related to my adopted dad and that's how
i became adopted by my parents was
he knew of okay through his ex-wife's
family and his his kids from his first
marriage um who were actually the ones
that brought me home
and so i was staying with them and
my parents really wanted to have kids my
mom wasn't able to
and they knew that i needed a home and
so i was really fortunate in that i
didn't wind up in the system because
right family and friends showed up for
me and took me home yeah but i
was real close you know and and i
i always look at my life as this series
of like
incredibly fortunate events where i just
happened to be in the right place at the
right time and like my life took
a really different journey you know
and i think that's a great perspective
because i can imagine some people being
like man i [ __ ] got scrooge i was
born in jail and then okay
and you know here's the thing is like i
had to get through and you know i talked
a lot about that in my book unsweetened
and i
talk about it a lot because i think
for one thing i know that uh you know
growing up as an adoptee there was
i think it's there's less of a stigma
now but when i was young you know my mom
was always like we don't want to talk
about this because
they were afraid that
all of that coming out about me that
somehow people would look at me
different
and now i'm like i don't give a [ __ ] how
people look at me like you know i mean i
am who i am and i i
i've survived you know i've had
some obstacles thrown at me but i've
also had some really wonderful
experiences so
that's life right like you sometimes
start off in a shitty place and then and
it's not so bad um when when
you
got pregnant we were were you thinking
oh god my kids are going to be
alcoholics
i mean that was definitely a that's
always a fear right like is are my kids
gonna be [ __ ] up too
am i [ __ ] i mean that's just a
parental fear of like am i is this the
thing that's gonna put them in therapy
is this the is this the conversation is
this time that i snap and yell gonna be
the thing that like right sticks with
them but i also know like for me it
i was raised by the most normal
non-drinking
right
like so there for me in every respect i
still [ __ ] up because i had my own
[ __ ] to deal with so like trying to
raise teenagers especially now man my
daughters are 13 and almost 11. and it's
terrifying
but i also know like
i have to you know
i've learned through my adventures in in
sobriety and all that like i have to
learn to give them the dignity of their
own experience too
and hope that i've put in place the
right right things and and also know
that they're gonna [ __ ] up and it's not
it i
it's not all about me like i can't take
all of my kids
[ __ ] and be like oh it's me i did it
you know right
it's scary
i was at one of my uh
one of my get-togethers right with sober
friends yeah oh yeah and um
after our get together this this mother
sort of called for like a little little
pow wow
you know we're all sort of standing
around you know everyone's kind of going
home except for us we're we're talking
and she says i've got my my i think she
was talking about her son if i remember
if there's like the kid was like eight
years old or something she says my son
is showing such signs of being an
alcoholic but he's never even took a
took a drink yet it's everybody you know
and like like i don't know what to do
because like i can't see like oh you
gotta like you know but she says part of
me wants to like just hand him a beer
and a joint let him get tuned and just
be like [ __ ] by the time you're 15
maybe you'll get your [ __ ] together
instead of starting then and [ __ ] it
up for a while right
i mean that's the thing right like you
know and my kids i always like to say
that
you know when i got sober too one of the
things
that i learned was that
practicing these principles and all my
affairs also includes my parenting right
so my kids
are aware of
the guiding principles of my life and
all that stuff and you know at the end
of the day
they're gonna make their own choices and
i just have to hope that whatever
they've heard and instilled and know
will be relevant or or i'll luck out and
they'll be [ __ ] normal and and
they'll read my book you know which of
course they now know about and their
friends talk about all [ __ ]
and they'll be like i don't want to be
like her that sounds terrible
probably not but you know what teenager
ever says that but
when i was working on my book i i found
myself thinking dude i'm [ __ ] gnarly
that what part did you think that all of
it
was
yeah like i had this documentary about
my downward spiral and i've seen it yeah
i i don't know if you remember we
actually met several times okay
i get so uncomfortable when people tell
me that they met me before i got sober
because odds are that means they have an
awful story to tell about me
but there's only a good story to tell
about what's gonna happen tonight when
my girl lux gets home because i'm gonna
pop a bluetooth tablet in my mouth and
chew it up and i'm gonna show her my
blue tongue because when she sees it she
literally cheers
she should man because blue chewed
tablets have the same active ingredient
as both viagra and cialis except they
only cost a fraction of the price and
they're chewable plus to get blue
tablets you don't have to have an
awkward in-person visit to the doctor's
office because when you go to
bluechew.com you just consult with one
of their medical providers right there
on the website couldn't be more simple
couldn't be more quick
and if you use the promo code stevo
bluechew.com you know what you're going
to get an entire month's supply of
bluetooth tablets completely for free
all you have to pay is five bucks for
shipping
come on could we get a better deal i'm
telling you i have so much fun when i
take my bluetooth tablet and rock lux's
world so hey man if you want to have
extra fun with your extra impressive
boner then get on over to bluechew.com
and use the promo code stevo because
once again that gets you an entire
month's supply for free all you gotta
pay is five bucks for shipping it's a
really good time so enjoy yourself now
let's get back to this
when we were both in not a great place
the fact that i even remember it is
shocking
you lived next door when you were
uh in that building right off sunset
sure
you lived next door to my friend jay
okay
jason
and he was also a
we were it was just not a good time for
any of us let's put it that way
and i seem to remember being out on a on
the balcony and somehow
someone's shoes maybe mine got thrown
over and like down in between the
building and then there was like
like i couldn't leave because i didn't
have shoes i mean i could have left but
then we were like i don't know it was
there was a lot going on in both our
that place and your apartment so it was
a wild ride and i i've run into you
several times so wow hi again
like it was like
like rolling dice like to
meet me back then you know it could have
been like a fun experience it could have
been an awful experience same here i'm
sure you know i've taught i still
have a few friends that i like partied
with back in the day who have
i've stayed in contact with like you
know
are cool people that weren't [ __ ]
and made it through and
and i always say i'm like was i
was i as bad as i thought i was and they
were like well
i mean not always
right but you know i did have the
nickname kanye mess that was my that's
great my friend dutch gave me that
nickname uh
and when i used to spend a lot of time
at the roosevelt hotel okay and uh yeah
um how much sobriety do you have now uh
i
stopped drinking uh
what is it now
2011. okay so it's been it's been a
while it's been a while and like
i i was talking about this the other day
i was talking to somebody and i was like
you know i thought i'd be
the girl to like die with a cocktail in
my hand like that was my plan well my
plan was to be done by 30. i didn't
think i'd see my 30th birthday hit me
either um and that was
the way i lived you know i was like [ __ ]
it none of this matters
just go as hard as you can and like the
fact that i made it out of the
situations that i often put myself in
in one piece uh is
pretty remarkable i count my blessings
for sure
um
but yeah i i you know i didn't think i'd
see my 30th birthday so like i'm 39 now
and i'm like wow extra you know
what was the rock bottom for you
you know i don't know that there was
like
but the last day the last day were you
just like i gotta get help um
you know it was interesting i actually
stopped drinking and and
using like
a couple years before my sprite was like
but i had relapsed after i got in a car
accident and i was using um muscle
relaxers because i broke my arm and
really [ __ ] up my neck and all that
and i just started taking
like
two three selmas at a time and it was a
really short
it was
jesus christ i was i think i wound and i
i'm pretty sure i've talked about this
before but like i wound up at swingers
the diner swingers like trying to hold a
fork and i was just like ah my friend
was there like what's wrong
yeah and she's sober she was like dude
and i
it had been
i don't know maybe a month not even like
it was a very short
time from like
i was using them and then using them
inappropriately and then it was like i
just can't do this anymore those things
killed people they do i remember my
doctor if you drank on soma like you
might just not wake up drink on somas
also if you detox suddenly off of them
yeah they can cause really gnarly
seizures and all that i mean i i worked
in treatment for uh a while before
coming back to fuller house i worked in
treatment for like five or six years wow
and uh yeah i remember you know that was
the thing that i learned i was like oh
glad i didn't die that's right yeah wow
um and you don't hear about somas
anymore it's like they kind of went away
they went i mean they went away
i mean and i think it's also it's like
so not something in my
i'm i'm sure
if i you know asked i'm sure i could
find them but like it's so not even in
my realm like
that anymore
um
working in recovery did you ever hear
that like statistically
the
the jobs that
people have the highest rate of relapse
are jobs where they work in recovery
yeah it's a it's
one of the most stressful things i've
ever done you know i was a
i worked uh i started as a tech and then
worked my way up and um was a director
of operations for a while
and so i oversaw you know a staff of
like 120 people and a bunch of different
houses and like
you know often times you're hiring
people that have been there for a year
and then they're moving out and they
want to you know so
i think that's part of it too is a lot
of people even if they have a you know
the year requirement um
it's hard and it's it's a hard
environment to work in it's there's a
huge burnout rate
um my boyfriend now is a social worker
and has his masters
uh and you know works as a case manager
and social worker and therapist and all
that and it is it's hard you're my best
friend's a therapist she takes on
people's [ __ ] all day long right and
it's hard
you know
it's a lot but i love i did love it i
was very fortunate in that
i
went into the world of recovery and kind
of threw myself in i was making 10 bucks
an hour as a tech for a while and right
emptying trash cans and i was like
okay this is just what it is and i was
fine with that um
but it's you know it's a lot to take on
because you care about these people and
it's you know sober's not easy and it's
not pretty right it also i think
feels pretty slippery to put your
recovery out there like publicly like i
know i i did that in a big way right and
at a certain point
like i really kind of tried to
back off of that yeah i do too like i
don't talk about it as often anymore
like
it's just something that i'm like it you
know it's not all that i am and i know
people are like always fascinated by
like
you know like what was the worst point
like i don't know it was all
i had fun and then there were moments
that i like wound up in the hospital you
know with acute alcohol poisoning or
something or
i wound up you know like passed out on a
sidewalk for hours and my friends
couldn't get me up or like you know
there was a lot of shitty times but
there was fun times too but then it just
became
more shitty times than good times and
then it was like now did you have fun
the last four years of of me using like
i i didn't have fun once i was
positive that i was having a blast right
right but were you really like the
stress my god it was constant just
constantly [ __ ] up everything i
thought i was
so cool i thought that like i was having
the greatest time
and like every once in a while like
that wasn't the case
and but like actually all the time i was
awful um
when i had kids that really changed it
for me like i
after
i had zoe my my older daughter um
i was trying to get sober again you know
i had quit drinking when i was pregnant
and then it was like she was born and i
was like
i mean i went from [ __ ] partying to
being a mom and i didn't i didn't know
what the [ __ ] i was doing it was
terrifying and
i started drinking again and then it was
like i've got to get sober but i will
say
that was the point in my life that i
really
dealt with the huge resentment of being
adopted and of my mom not being able to
get her [ __ ] together enough
like my my biological mom i think i
always held on to that resentment like
was it me
why why didn't why wasn't i good enough
why wasn't i
so you know why couldn't i change you
and i think when i got to the point
after i had my daughter and i was
struggling to get sober and quit
drinking and all of a sudden i realized
i was like
oh [ __ ]
this has nothing to do
with her
this is my
sickness and my addiction issue that i
have to deal with
and suddenly it was like i understood
who
that my biological mother was and and
that she actually did
the best thing she could for me and that
it how sad that she couldn't get it
you know what i mean and it just it gave
me a different perspective on it having
gone through it myself i suddenly saw
her in a whole new way
and this huge amount of
forgiveness
came about and that was really
that
was
you know when i could drinking that was
it like i
had a drink since then
um you know and again like i said i
relapsed on the other stuff but
i hadn't had a drink since then you know
and um
it was i i that was what i needed you
know that was a resentment that i didn't
know
how to heal until i was in it
wow um
as i understand it adopted kids it's
almost like a rite of passage to try to
like track down your biological parents
yeah
uh i did i mean i was easy one has
passed away and well they're both dead
now i never got to meet him but i did
finally get some pictures
um
and
that was i think all i really wanted you
know i remember
so [ __ ] cheesy but i remember
the movie antoine fisher with denzel
washington
okay and i remember seeing that movie
and it's about like the guy never meets
his you know his biological mom's the
[ __ ] crackhead and is a mess and all
this stuff and there was this one scene
in it where he meets her
and he's so disappointed
because she's still getting loaded and
her life's still [ __ ] up and he's like
gone off and gotten his [ __ ] together
and he's like this whole thing where
he's like i just i kept thinking maybe
you'd come around the corner
and like have ice cream for me or like
be there or that you he's like i saw you
like this golden angel and i like it hit
me because i was like oh [ __ ]
i have this really idealized version
of what this person was and in doing
that i've like
taken away her humanity a little bit
because i have this expectation
and so like being able to kind of
connect and understand her in a little
bit different way once i was a mom
really changed things for me that's
heavy it is it is deep and heavy and
deep and heavy
i mean
[ __ ] it like it was this is you know i'm
it's funny like
i'm at that point now in my life where
i'm like if we're not talking about this
[ __ ] what's the point like right i
suffer from terrible anxiety still ptsd
depress you know the whole fun gamut of
like
this is such an inappropriate question
but i'll just go for it do you take any
fun like antidepressant meds of course
thank god
they're fun but they're fun but they're
necessary yeah oh my god for me like and
i'm no doctor and i would never
recommend anything but personally for me
zoloft is so absolutely crucial to me
it's true and and i think
i you know it's interesting too there i
there are some meds that i use
um
that have saved my life yeah you know
i'm not i'm not
like suicidally depressed 100 that's
exactly it and i
i look at it as like look my my brain
just works a little differently
and it's not always the best i'm trying
you know i meant i do i go to therapy i
i i do all the things that i know i'm
supposed to do
but my brain just works a little
differently and so i i know i've seen
people in the program really shame
people for
uh psych meds for psych meds and things
like that and i'm like dude outside help
[ __ ] outside help outside issue
not sure not your you know plus
in the history of zola loft i don't
think anybody has ever taken it like for
fun right you know but you know people
you know they're and i think
often as any humans group of humans get
together and all of a sudden everybody
gets a little judgy right yeah sure but
like the the the difference is
if if i'm not taking zoloft
then it takes a very minor disturbance
for me from my head to just go straight
to some crazy suicidal ideation right oh
yeah yeah like that's it everything's
done just let me just check out for sure
and and i don't think that i ever got
anywhere near
actually like
being proactive about suicide i just
simply wasted
untold hours of time right wallowing in
this
dark right planning out what it would
you know the how i would do it and and
the the sad reality
is that uh i was
always in my fantasies far too concerned
with what would happen after i died to
have ever been serious about dying well
because you're like but wait
i want to be there though i want to see
whatever
i mean my plans were always like oh like
like how how will i make sure that my
body's not found
you know like and i had such i had such
crazy ways for that i was gonna
oh boy here we go
why wouldn't you want your body found
because i wanted to just [ __ ]
disappear and not i'm not that like
elders
or what
and that's but that's really what you
wanted right you didn't necessarily want
to die you just wanted to disappear i
just if you don't want it
yeah
that would make me like somehow like
last forever you know if people didn't
know like right right you're going to be
a constant mystery that people are going
to be trying to solve right right and
the arrogance of that right 100 percent
that anyone's going to probably give a
[ __ ] anyway for sure for sure
uh so so my plan was my favorite of the
players your favorite right the one that
you would read those weren't practical
ones but but my favorite of the plans
was
to rent a cube truck okay like like like
a box truck like a u-haul box truck
right okay now
i would have like a super old-school car
in the back of the box truck okay okay
right so it's all sealed up right and
they're just super that you can super
carpet
and like right right right now the box
truck would be
like parked near a body of water okay
right actually but not parked it would
actually be
uh in drive mode except it would have a
huge block of ice on the break
so i get
holy [ __ ] you really
went for it so i go in the back in the
car and i get going with that plus on
top of that i got a hose coming out of
the exhaust pipe of the cube truck
running in so i'm double i'm double time
right yeah because even in your death
you'll be alcoholic about it
right
because even as i'm dying i want [ __ ]
more right yeah 100 yeah so i got all
the carbon monoxide coming from the cube
truck as well as coming from the car in
the cube truck all just hosed right into
the car with the windows right here yes
none of this is a recommendation of how
to do it because carbon monoxide is is
terribly unsuccessful so much of the
time and it leaves you a [ __ ]
vegetable right yeah and then look none
of it's good because it's always the the
the you know but it's really dope that
for the ice to melt and then the truck
drives itself into the body of water and
is never found because it's just under
this random body of water in the middle
of nowhere
that's a plan and a half
pretty [ __ ] cool
thank god for zoloft
and this has been a this has been an
advertisement tour
wow and it's crazy too because there was
one point where i was in a relationship
with someone who really looked down on
the idea of men psych meds and and i
actually got off of them and in black
and white i could notice the difference
man and then i got back on him and like
everything was okay yeah no i i think
i've i you know i've gotten to the place
in my life where i'm like you know what
whatever i have to do to like save my
mental health
i'm gonna do it and i'm willing to do it
in like i'm good you know this is this
is my path this is my journey this is my
life and like i think
i've just gotten to a place now you know
past all of that stuff where i'm like
good i have
[ __ ] anxiety i mean i'm you know
today i was a mess just like i couldn't
executive functioning was out the window
today and i don't know why it was just
one of those days where my brain was
like
eating itself alive
but
i know it'll pass i know it'll get
better and i have a great partner who's
like
so supportive of me and he's like just
just come sit down it's okay you know
you're good
but my life is so
good today and i also know like
i've survived the [ __ ] you know what i
mean like yeah it's miserable there are
some days when you're like i can't
[ __ ] do this i i can't i can't do
this
but you do it and you get through it and
then eventually you look back and you go
oh [ __ ] i did it you know
and
i just i was so fortunate getting to
come back like and do fuller house i got
to direct an episode wow super cool um
which is something that i want to focus
on like i'm you know having more
meetings with different networks and
stuff about getting back into directing
that's really where i want to focus my
energy is like directing producing i've
got a couple scripts that i'm working on
with people and
you're
playing the lead in something coming up
are you got a lead role in a movie
um i did a uh i sh actually we shot it
during quarantine in november yeah um
and it's called will you be my corn my
porn time
uh cute little rom-com about like a
relationship that develops over during
quarantine over zoom and then you know
they
luckily there's a vaccine i mean we shot
this in november when there wasn't a
vaccine and i remember thinking like
god i really hope that there is one
otherwise this is gonna be people are
gonna be like oh [ __ ] look at them
they're happy now they got a vaccine
we're still sitting inside you know oh
wow um but yeah that'll be coming out i
think sometime
i think we're gonna try to release it
around valentine's day next year sounds
like a modern day you've got mail
exactly very similar very similar um
and uh yeah and i'm you know working on
writing a script with a friend or
actually she's writing it but i'm
working on trying to you know pitch that
and do stuff so
it's i would i i
i'm trying to remember that like this
this business is all it's up and down
you know right it's it's all over the
place and that's okay it's gnarly yeah
it's gnarly in between full house and
fuller house did you have like
show up and show big stuff going on yeah
oh yeah i did you know like i said i i
did um party five party five i did um
brotherly love when i first
uh finished full house i was like 13 14.
that was the lawrence brothers
um
and i did a few other things but then
like
i you know i got married really young
the first time how old it's been a few
uh i was 20 when i first got married
and um
you know my
i've ironically enough my husband was a
cop at the time which i know people now
are like you are married i'm like yeah i
know uh and then you know i started
getting sober and
being not sober and [ __ ] everything
up and
you know it's been
it's definitely been an up and down and
there was a time that i kind of walked
away from the business because i was
like you know
i don't know if it's what i want to do
anymore and
so i moved into working in treatment and
i loved that you know i was i wanted to
be a case manager i want to be a
therapist
um
and then fuller house like came about
and we were pitching that
and then that happened and my life
completely pivoted again and i got back
to doing the thing that like i said i
feel most at home doing yeah and still
trying to you know build on that and
direct and do other stuff and i've got
my podcast never thought i'd say this oh
cool that i do we're we just started
season four again we just launched a
youtube channel nice um and it's me and
my best friend celia behar who um we our
girls are about the same age and we just
talk about all of our parenting fuck-ups
and fails and like how we don't know
what the hell we're doing and just the
weird [ __ ] you know it's a very raw
inappropriate look at parenting um like
my mom says you'll love the show if you
don't mind the f word
nice but uh yeah you know i'm just
trying to stay busy in doing that stuff
but how long have you been doing the
podcast uh we just celebrated our two
year anniversary but we've done four
seasons so we've done like two seasons a
year okay and where can they find it
they can find it anywhere on apple uh on
itunes spotify stitcher um everywhere
anywhere you can get your podcasts you
can down you can download it and
subscribe to never thought i'd say this
and on our youtube oh that's the name of
it that's the name of it never thought
i'd say i'd say
because we started out like neither one
of us
we were like i never thought i'd be a
parent
and all the and not only that but like
all the [ __ ] you're like i never thought
i'd have to ask someone like please
don't lick the toilet like i just
you know things that you have to say to
kids as you're parenting where you're
like i never ever thought this string of
words would be put together and i'd have
to direct it at another human being
because what the [ __ ] is happening right
now that's funny that's epic yeah did
i know that netflix is like notoriously
like kind of like
not uh
open about their their numbers you know
so
sometimes they choose to say oh with
this many households whatever like they
like and it's never
like necessarily an accurate number you
never really know um but like
independent
you know
i don't even know what like companies
have people
looked into it
what their numbers are and i do remember
that uh i believe fuller house the year
the season it premiered was like one of
their top watched
shows that entire year
cool so i guess now they did well one
through ten you always know what the
title was trending but like they never
to but that could be anything
and and i think the top ten it's also
like
what your algorithm said you know my
title
[Music]
i don't know i don't know but i do
notice like sometimes my top ten i'm
like oh i don't have that in
my kids yeah it's not [ __ ] true crime
like really creepy disturbing
i'm all about the [ __ ] serial killer
i'm actually doing one of those like
hunter killer things like my boyfriend
got it for me for valentine's day like a
six month subscription to
one of those things where you like you
know
hunt the killer whatever it's a you know
it's a fake one but i love that [ __ ] wow
i love it hey when full
how many eyeballs were on full house at
its peak
oh god i know we made it to the number
one a few times but we were in the top
ten it was never like ten minutes
abc when we were like the tgif channel
and it was uh and it was prime time um
right before family matters friday
nights
yeah we did we i mean
like
did you break 20 million something like
that yeah a lot i mean and we you know
we would fluctuate but we were often in
the top ten occasionally i think we made
it to number one depending on the
episode so we we were
it was a huge abc show you know and it's
right huge yeah and it's huge on netflix
so like it said there's no way of really
wondering
when it was
right when it was more popular but it
makes sense that it would be more
popular now because you've got multiple
generations well we've got multiple
generations and we're also it's all over
the world
like we shot an episode uh in japan for
fuller house we went over there for a
few weeks
it was insane like we arrived at the
airport and there were like 300 people
there waiting for us we would get
followed everywhere we have people
camping out in our hotel like full house
and fuller house are huge in japan also
i'm huge in brazil i have a ridiculous
amount of following in brazil so if
anyone out there from brazil is
listening what's up
um germany
um where's the craziest place that like
you've had fans reach out to your oh my
god i mean all over like i i i've had
fan mail literally from all over the
world i know fuller house is in like 56
countries
um wow i remember one of the seinfeld
guys was like dude i was in indonesia
and and i walked into this house
and they're all huddled around this tv
watching seinfeld yeah
yeah what do you need i'm just gonna put
this down so we can get a good thumbnail
oh yeah yeah yeah there we go okay
right on right um
yeah yeah that's that's crazy man yeah i
think for you the craziest place that i
when i've been with you would be uh
madagascar
madagascar yeah i remember we were
shooting wild boys and uh we were on um
uh what was uh
the borneo the little islands in
indonesia and we were filming with some
like like indigenous tribe and they were
filming and being part of their sheriff
i would have seen web boys yeah i
understand this uh this this indigenous
tribe guy like points to my tattoo that
i got in the the hummer right at any
point he goes offroad tattoo
oh really awful that's crazy i couldn't
understand what he was like what a fruit
tattoo
he said offroad tattoo yeah
i mean it's crazy and and i always think
about too you know the impact
that
i've been able to have and now with
social media even more like it's still
out there and you know i'm super
politically active now and like very
much involved in a lot of that i just uh
joined the board of um
a uh a super pac here in l.a or in
california that is really pushing young
progressive candidates um and trying to
get them elected
uh and you know i was really involved in
all the protests i was out at actions
constantly
um
i
you know support a lot of uh
you know the dude didn't decline like
all of that protest art and stuff like
that like
that's my wheelhouse now so i i know i
definitely you know piss a lot of people
off but uh right but it's also something
i'm super passionate about so does that
who's the boss was before full house huh
uh right around the same time yeah yeah
alyssa's on there are you friends with
the listeners i am because when you say
you know like your wheelhouse is
political now i feel like she's pretty
political she's super political yes i am
friends with her are your political
sort of uh
like what it was ideologies aligned
we're similar i'm definitely much
farther left than okay than most
uh people so yeah okay you know i'm one
of those crazy leftist hollywood liberal
[ __ ]
all right
is there
i mean you i mean the back of my shirt
has like
you know all kinds of stuff on it for
good you know
from change.org if it's uh left to
promote respect then call me left yeah
yeah it's i mean it's it's all about
just trying to really broaden the
broadener horizons and make people aware
of what the world is what's actually
going on in the world okay since you
brought up politics can i ask you
uh
would you have voted for bernie sanders
absolutely [ __ ] me too absolutely i
would have voted for bernie um i also
like to uh uh some of elizabeth warren's
platforms but i don't think you know and
i really
i wish we could get more progressive
candidates in which is you know a lot of
the candidates that i am now working
with and promoting with this super bloom
pack are people that are endorsed by
bernie and that are very you know
it's really trying to push environmental
issues
justice issues and all that [ __ ] because
oh my god my girl said something so
[ __ ] funny the other night i was like
trying to say like i was trying to like
make a joke or something because with
all the the the heat records i was like
god i was like babes
global warming is such a hoax
right i was joking and she says of
course it's a hoax the world is flat
did you watch that documentary flat
earthers
oh my god there's a [ __ ] no no dude
if you want to lose
no but you have to because it's so like
it's i i watched it like this the whole
time just like
these i think i did see something it's
on
space is fake the the slightest fake the
earth is flat and here the best part is
though is these [ __ ] people
oh my god
so they're doing experiments right
to to yeah i didn't see that with the
lasers the lasers yeah yeah they don't
and and it disproves their theory and
they're like well we need to adjust this
so that it proves our theory and you're
right
that's how science works
there's so many there's so many like
things that just are problematic for
flat earthers like say for example if
you're going to fly to london england
you're going to fly east right across
america and then across the atlantic
however if you're going to fly north
right fly that way yeah
right
conversely if you're gonna fly to
australia then you go the other way
right because it's shorter because that
would
suggest roundness well no no but it's a
big it's a big bubble it's a big bubble
steve it's we're living in a dome it's a
dome but my question is where's the
[ __ ] sun go
how how is it that every other planet
is round
except for us what are you talking about
that's not how gravity works well also
in like dubai they have the world's
tallest building there where they have a
different the sunset is later because
it's so high right that it's the sun
sets later but they're like it's just
because it's big
they're out there they're totally out
there i posted at one point because like
everyone was talking about flat earth
and uh back on wild boys
i i
went in a russian mig fighter jet like
faster than the speed of sound to the
edge of the earth's atmosphere
and i like to call myself a [ __ ]
cosmonaut for that which is the russian
term for astronaut right of course chris
pontius made the point if you go to the
edge of a woman's [ __ ] that doesn't
make you not a virgin
[Laughter]
right but the thing was though i went up
and
i went what the [ __ ] did chris do what
what plane is he hugging yeah how did
you get to go on that and chris did it
because there's only room for one person
and uh
i don't know i wanted to do it
right but the thing was um
i went up at like noon and it was fully
like not a cloud in the sky totally blue
you know like sunny sunny at noon and
then going up even though it was only to
the edge of the earth's atmosphere and
not you know beyond it um
it was like fully by the time we got up
like to whatever however high it was it
wasn't sunny anymore it was like
straight [ __ ] dark and i was looking
at the earth the earth and it was curved
and i took this wild that's so
that's amazing i don't have the balls to
do that but like that [ __ ] is amazing i
took a picture
of the the [ __ ] like there's dark and
it's like looked like [ __ ] space too
right and i and i posted that for the
flat earthers i was like dude i took
this picture and they're like yeah
[ __ ] fish eye lens [ __ ] makes
everything curved
that's so crazy dude you're like
what
what like it's just like i said i
watched the whole documentary like oh my
god i remember i did watch it when he
played
sometimes i
you just have to watch
the [ __ ] about the the edge of right of
reason
because i'm like i need to know
what these like what right what's going
on on the other side and you're just
like wow so like this is what happens
when you defund education for like two
generations you know right you get
people who don't think that the earth is
round
it's it's it's uh it's something else so
full houses still go sorry fuller house
is still going yeah
no it's not we finished in 2019 we did
five seasons and we were really
fortunate we ended in november of 2019
right before the pandemic so we got to
have a big
celebration and you know everybody on
set and it wasn't like a [ __ ] weird
thing right and and you've got the will
you be my quarantine
coming out that's going to be coming out
next year and then um a campaign like a
full-length like
i never thought i'd say this podcast
which is season four just came out uh
last week i think you're in the minority
of podcasts for having seasons that i
can't think that threw us off because
we're like season 1 well we just i mean
we do it that way for like how many
episodes per season 24 24
okay yeah we usually do it that way
because then we're like oh my god i need
to take a rest and like figure out who
the hell we're going to have on next
season we're cycling
we're psycho we don't rest
i
[Music]
we hate weekends we hate holidays we
hate anything that stops productivity
yeah um what about your your social
media handle social media you can find
me at jodie sweetin on instagram and
twitter
um at official jody sweetin on facebook
and uh i just i'm going to start a tick
tock
because i made a bet that once my best
friend celia got to 10 000 followers on
instagram that i'd started tick tock
because i'm like [ __ ] i'm too old for
this [ __ ] right i just posted a tick
tock before we started recording i bet
it's already been taken down by tick
tock for violating community guidelines
they're the most sensitive platforms uh
well tick-tock's super sensitive i
instagram really didn't like me for a
while like during 2020
uh i definitely because i was so active
in a lot of protests i got shadow banned
a lot
i got my live turned off if i was at
certain actions like i couldn't post
live i couldn't hear you you always
think that instagram would be like
pretty aligned with that
like i said i'm pretty far out oh you're
like straight antifa
yeah i was joking i was joking my dad
i'm like i'm the president of antifa i
have to go to a meeting yeah i didn't
even know i'm like
i said that like as a joke like not
knowing if i got it right is antifa far
left yeah yeah oh that's antifa auntie
is not far antifa is just anti-fascist
and i you know
i think
we fought a big war about that i'm
pretty sure america is pretty
anti-fascist
i'm dying to know how many like comments
this podcast gets where it's like
unsubscribe
i got into a huge thing on on and
declines post the other day about with
like pro pro lifers and pro choice like
it was i'm not pro-life or pro-choice
i'm pro-abortion
there you go that well they haunt
because i think i think some people
should not be allowed to have kids okay
so here's the thing
uh i don't know if you follow in decline
they're a big street art graffiti art
protest art collective and uh
i'm friends with them
and
they broke in they went to the christ of
the ozarks
i don't know what that means in missouri
the price of the ozarks is a is a
smaller replica of that big giant jesus
in rio okay gotcha and they have one
there and it's like a jesus theme park
ozarks being like missouri yeah okay and
they went in and they hung a giant sign
off the christ of the ozarks it says god
bless abortions and so i was like thank
you for doing this like this is you know
you could with all those restrictions
you have to get a license to catch a
fish
right yeah
you got to bring anything you're [ __ ]
cool right any [ __ ] can gather any
castle can have a kitten it would be
kind of cool if you had to get a license
to become a parent
a class or two right like you're ready
to get a license right wouldn't it be
kind of cool if to become a parent you
had to like like take a class in
developmental psychology so you could
understand what the implications of
certain things that happened like how
how malleable how impressionable like
how important the uh a human's first
experiences are absolutely babysit an
infant for the weekend and you're like
[ __ ] this well and you know it's funny
my thirteen-year-old daughter made the
point she was like um
so if you're 15 like you can't adopt a
baby because you're not so you know
fiscally responsible enough and you know
you're not mature
but you can have a baby at 15 and no
one's going to stop you she's like so
why
wouldn't you want the option you know it
was just an interesting point but i like
i said i i definitely get into it with
people on the internet because i
really in 2020 like all of my [ __ ] went
out the window there was very few
hanging on
and then the rest of them were just like
you know what peace out
you're going to go crazy and i was like
yep i'm ready i i i love that so much so
i just don't i at this point i'm like i
don't i don't have time to just not be
fully who i am like i'm 39 years old i'm
over the [ __ ] the world is on fire
like literally
who cares just like i got you got to
stand for something and i am very
passionate about the things i believe in
and i feel like i have a platform and a
perspective
that hopefully will reach people that
maybe
aren't aware of some of the things you
know what i mean right and or people
just [ __ ] hate me that's cool too
like i lose followers all the time i
gain followers all the time i'm like
right
i
you know i know who i am
yeah i generally try to like steer clear
of politics and stuff you know just
because like i don't really care to
alienate people and it's just like too
much it's too much of a of a
you know ah
yeah and i i mean i definitely you know
before i i
i
for your bravery to to be in that form
but i think i can safely say nobody
cares about stevo's political opinion
right and it's not even
i don't i know that like jody sweetens
political opinion isn't the thing it's
more like
you know i know that i reach an audience
probably of a lot of
middle america
you know
white people
that maybe don't
aren't aware of some of these things or
or are un you know aren't exposed to
the diversity of communities that we
have here in l.a and that i've grown up
with and you know
i just
feel like
being
trying to be an ally and trying to you
know talk about that stuff and i had to
i'd definitely consider it
before i started doing it like i that
first post
when i posted about uh it was about
actually um sexual assault and i posted
about it and i knew it was going to be
really polarizing because it was
christine blasey ford's testimony or
whatever and i posted about my own
experience with it
and i was like well here we go and you
know there was one little [ __ ] went
flying away and then
and then like 2020 happened and i was
like oh let's go like and i you know
i just i went for it so
i i always say you know i'm
i don't want to alienate anyone i'm
trying to educate people but also if you
come to my instagram page and you start
talking [ __ ] to me
i'm gonna go at you because it's like
you came to my door
wow knocked on it
and then
yeah so then you get mad when i punch
you in the face after i've told you to
leave and you don't like that's just
what it is so you'll engage with it huh
like negativity um
i will it's not even that i engage with
it but it's like if people come on at me
you know i've got death threats i've
gotten all kinds of wild [ __ ]
if people come on my page and want to
insult me directly
i'm like
i'll have some words for you and i have
some things to say
because like i say i go you can't you
showed up here
and came here to engage in this
conversation i didn't follow you i don't
go on other pages
but by having words for them you're
giving attention to them and like kind
of where like in my view it's just if
it's negative [ __ ] delete blocks i do
that with a lot of stuff it depends on
what it is it depends on if people are
like you know you
you know
i have i've had some people on there who
i will engage it with that are
completely opposite of me and i can
engage in
calm debate all day long like i'll have
a conversation with you but if you want
to come on my page and say some [ __ ]
like
i'm going to say something back and then
i'm going to be like and now i'm done
with you yeah all right well i'm going
to tell everybody to go to your page and
say nice stuff stay nice yeah and that's
the thing like i post about fun stuff a
lot of the time too but i post about my
life and what i'm really passionate
about i hate
the narcissism of
instagram and social media it's why i
don't
like having a lot of platforms because
i'm like
what the [ __ ] does why do i want to see
my face more you know what i mean like i
just i'm so it's like
i it feels so narcissistic and it's so
not me that like
at least when i feel like i am
trying to take action or trying to
promote something that i believe in it
feels a little less
about me i just don't like making care
about me
i've always been about making everything
as evidenced by your suicide plan
yeah i'm a card carrying [ __ ]
attention [ __ ] all the way through
you're kidding i've never watched
seasons of jackass wild boys you're
kidding no wow we went we went well over
an hour
oh good okay oh good it's been a treat
um anything else we can direct people to
uh
not right now but i'm sure you know
follow me at jodie sweetin on instagram
twitter all that i'm always talking
about new projects i post a lot of stuff
for the podcast at never thought i'd say
this you can also follow it there
um
but yeah i'm you know hoping for
directing projects i'm really
kind of that's my goal for this year i
like try and set a goal each year let's
get you a gig of scarlett johansson's
sisters let's do that
make it [ __ ] happen yeah
i love it that's what we'll do is
everyone go and somehow like just start
posting about that i mean i see it i see
it too yeah it works for me awesome hey
thank you so so much you're so welcome
thank you for having me on yeah
yeah
what can i say man that was a good time
maybe not as good of a time as lux and i
are about to have considering she just
got home and it's blue chew tablet time
but still the jody sweden episode was a
lot of fun and thank you for sticking
around to the very end because as i
always say it's you guys who stick
around at the very end who mean the most
to me
and hopefully i'm going to see you guys
on my bucket list tour man because
covert allowing i'm [ __ ] going
everywhere yeah
okay baby